this program is being presented to you
by the Harris international winter
school on gravity and lights okay so
good morning everyone it's Ash Wednesday
today and as you can see it's rather
bleak
so let's saw what light right so
yesterday you've you've seen that he's
starting to talk about lensing in
particular and today I want to discuss
the theory behind lensing so the first
lecture I'm going to talk about lensing
from the point of view of general
relativity and of course we've been
discussing the deflection of light and
of course when I talk about deflection
of light I really mean deflection in
space right so we have to find a way of
going from the spacetime four dimensions
down to some three dimensional action
space in which we can talk about the
deflection and that's the subject of
optical geometry okay
so what I'm going to do today in the
first lecture is to discuss Fermat's
principle of course what form it takes
in general relativity and then we move
on to optical geometry but in order to
actually use some real calculations of
course we have to specialize the
space-time from which we start and that
would just be the optical geometry
corresponding to static space times and
these optical geometries are actually
Romanian
and then within this framework of
Romanian optical geometries I can
actually discuss lensing and we'll see
that lensing is a global effect so you
will see how to apology of what the
particular surface that we look at
actually determines where we whether we
can have multiple images and what the
deflection angle is and so on and the
technique to use to discuss global
properties there is the Gauss Binet
theorem so that's the final topic of
that first lecture now I think it's
probably useful to remind ourselves of
Fermat's principle in classical optics
so what if sue Ellen's principle say
well actually there's an earlier form
which goes back to antiquity by heron
which is that light always takes the
shortest path so the shortest path in
space well that's only true if you have
a homogeneous optically medium but more
generally Fermat observed that light
always takes the shortest path in time
right so the state of the statement is
if you integrate along possible paths
and of course the time it takes to to
traverse a length of path which would be
the speed times DL right in the speed is
given by actually 1 over speed it's the
speed of light divided by the refractive
index n this will be 1 in vacuum or will
be a number greater than 1 and that can
depend on space so now if we look at the
variation of this and look for
stationery curse and these will
correspond to actual light rate now of
course this formulation of firmus
principle does not work in general
relativity because the length the the
full length in space time for
non-genetic is 0 of course so as to find
a way of rewriting this in general
activity
okay now in order to do this let's just
look at stationary spacetimes I'm not
sure if your conversation is basing from
the lectures in detail
so I'll set up so we look at space-time
that's a four dimensional differentiable
manifold about with Morenci metric and
the signature I'm going to use will be
minus plus plus plus like this right and
I want you to work in local charts of
course I'm using Greek indices to denote
coordinates in the space time and Latin
indices like this to note spatial
coordinates like this right and meu then
runs from zero up to three okay so sort
of basic set up now what's the
stationary space-time so definition so
it's called stationary space-time if it
has a time like killing vector field
let's call this T and so I think I've
come you've come across the the notion
of killing vector fields in the lecture
so certainly in the tutorials so what
this means of course is that first of
all T is time like so though signature
we want this to be the case and for the
electric field to be killing means that
it's it corresponds to a symmetry of the
metric so the leader rivet if of the
metric in the direction of T is equal to
zero so you've seen leader reviews
before of course so let's work out what
this condition means
all right so what are the components
well first of all we're going to turn
like this then because if you look at
the relative of T's supposed to get two
terms like that now let's suppose for
our killing vector field we choose
coordinates in such a way so you use
this notation for the basis that's
coordinate induced I guess you've seen
that before right so it's just a vector
field that has components one zero zero
zero so as you can see then these terms
would go and from this which is left
with the derivative of the metric
components with respect to time now all
of that of course is supposed to be 0
for T to be killing so you don't really
have to use Skilling's equation in this
particular case of course you can also
do that but we see now that the metric
components do not depend on time ok I
should rather say we can find a
coordinate system in which the metric
components do not depend on time as the
stationary vector field so we can now
write down the most general stationary
space-time
so let me write it as a line element
nice what will it look like
well the points we will have mixed terms
in space and time right at the time of
course and then a Romanian metric in
space and write it like this all right
so you can see all the possible metric
coefficients are covered with this is
Romanian this is a metric in
three-dimensional space it's just a
signature plus plus plus of course and
this is the mixing term mixing time and
space
now the point is of course that these
functions V the Omega s and also the H a
B do not depend on t symmetric if you
write it in component form with -3
squared you get the minus V squared
Omega s here
all right across the symmetry and then
the H ap okay so we need stationary
space times we also need the notion of
static space terms and also you've seen
this before so
so now we have our time like killing
vector field and the space-time will be
static if this time like killing vector
field is hypersurface orthogonal as its
called
now to define this I'd write down the
condition you need for Venus's theorem
it's a little bit fiddly I don't
actually need this for what we're going
to do later but for our purposes that
really means that in a particular
coordinate system there's no mixing
terms alright so this really means just
for us that the components Jean or a
zero that's why e this these components
Omega also vanish these are Omega is
actually have a nice symmetrical
interpretation so they're the spatial
part of what's called a twisting vector
for the space-time okay so this is a
stationary space-time in a static
space-time and now of course we want to
talk about light so let me first of all
remind you about no curves
all right what a lot of curves in gamma
so principle of course they're the maps
from some interval of the real line
let's say into your manifold and then of
course we want to use some parameter
ization so we go back down to our 4 and
let's call the parameter L for length if
you like
so we assigned to air xB of L right and
then another condition it's just to say
that the tangent vector of the null
curve has length 0 in our space-time
metric and of course as you know we can
write this as DX mu by the L D mu and
for short I might sometimes just write X
mu dot like this that's the tangent
vector to our curve and now condition
now out of all the possible no curves
that we have certain curves might be
dude Essex now of course you've seen the
condition for geodesics for non Jude
Essex will be no the curves which in
addition satisfies obviously the Judaic
equation so we might write this as the
covariant derivative of the tangent
vector with respect to themselves so
auto parallels is equal to zero that's
our condition for magnitude Essex so now
I would like to move on to firmest
principle and general activity we've got
all the basic set up along
so let's consider another curve again
right with another condition and suppose
we integrate it along the null curve
well because that's still going to be
zero right and I would also like to fix
the interval so real interval let's
let's go I'll probably let's just say
our parameter L only goes from 1 up to L
every from 0 up to 1 I mean all right
this so this will always be true from
other curves and let's see what happens
when we take the variation of this
equation well if you take the variation
you've probably seen this you can call
this n we get the functional derivative
right so we get the integral of the
Euler Lagrange equations
times of variation
plus well of course then there's the
variation at the start point and end
point of our curve so this will be the N
by d-x of mu delta x miu and then
evaluate it from 0 to 1 is equal to 0
you've probably seen this in the context
of the of deriving the geodesic equation
now actually writing this down is
slightly tedious are not going to do it
here on the blackboard explicitly if you
have problems doing this we can do it
later if you want but what you will get
is the following so let's look at this
term first L of course is given by G mu
nu DX mu by DL DX nu by DL I so this is
a notation G mu nu X of MU X love new
now the very v with respect to X dot
mule gives you two terms because of the
symmetry so this term then we'll just
give us two times
well G nu X dot mule we can write this
then as G of
well I can write it like this
much like this okay isn't it
that's nice right like this and then the
left-hand side
you recover the geodesic equation so we
actually also get a factor of two
overall which you have to take out and
there will be a minus sign and we get G
Delta x times to do this equation right
so this is two vectors
those are contracted by G in this way
that's the result it's not let's make
some observations let's suppose so
here's our our curve and we look at
variations right along the curve and
there will be variations at zero and
variations at at one the endpoint of our
interval let's suppose all curves start
with no variation at the beginning of
our interval okay
and then observe the following let's
suppose all curves also have no
variation at the endpoints really keep
the curves fixed at the parameter value
L equal to 0 and L equal to 1 and if
this is true for all possible variations
Delta X of L you see from this equation
that this implies right this term
vanishes and we just get the statement
that the integral from 0 to 1 of G Delta
x times the geodesic equation and to
Insadong L is equal to 0 so if this is
true for all variations this really
means then that nabla gamma komarov's
equal to 0 so we recover the GS equation
right I mean this is of course something
you know if you fix the variation of the
staffroom at the end point for all
possible variations then this of course
means that we're looking at a geodesic
but let's suppose we do not do this
let's suppose we're in a static
space-time
so then we can find a coordinate system
where time and space splits right we're
still assuming that the variation at the
start point is equal to zero
let's suppose the variation at the end
point is just in the time direction all
right so let's say Delta X is 1 we'll
just be some delta T times T mu let's
look at this equation again start right
from the second term yes so the integral
just here I don't know but it's fold
it's all for what possible variations
yeah non-degenerate yes that's the point
right
so in this just the the Judaic that you
get from keeping the endpoints the
endpoint in the stop point fixed for all
the possible variations but now I want
to look at a slightly different case I
want to look at the case that first of
all the metric is static and the
variation at the endpoint is just in the
time direction Delta x1 is delta T D mu
as it right sorry I mean so the picture
is really just we have our curve all the
variations start at the same point but
at the parameter value one the variation
is just in the time direction
alpha K vector yes
divisions exactly so let's look at
starting what does star imply so let me
write it down so I cancel I cancel the
tools because doesn't matter on the side
you take like this okay
so writing with some components gives
you a G mu nu then X mu gamma dot mule
evaluates it for 0 and 1 alright so this
will be G mu nu del X mu at 1 times the
tangent vector to the to the null
perfect one - well the same evaluated
our starting point that's zero right our
assumption the variation at the starting
point is zero now at 1 the variation we
say is only in the direction of the time
so this one will be zero mu delta T demo
dot new at 1 right but remember our
space time now is supposed to be static
and in particular coordinate system that
we have there are no mix terms right by
statistic
right the the 0h homes yes yeah thanks
alright so my statisti denote a is equal
to zero so all of this sum only one term
actually survives and that's the G
naught naught term so G naught Lord
delta T gamma dot zero at one but now
where the static space time we can
certainly assume that the G naught
naught term is nonzero we can certainly
assume that the time component of the
tangent vector is non zero right
so we're not allowed to rearrange this
equation here right we allowed now to
divide by those two terms that's the
crucial observation it will be true in
static space terms not necessarily in
other space we can now write DT is equal
to 1 over G naught naught gamma dot Lord
at 1 x where x does interval over here
right so this will we've derived from
star that's the outcome of our variation
but let's think about what this actually
means so if we have an arbitrary mother
curve we start with no variation at the
start point we get this equation for the
variation in the time direction the
killing direction at the endpoint for
static space-time now let's suppose our
variation was not actually about any
arbitrary node curve but actually you
know geodesic well of course we've seen
from a or I mean as you know anyway that
this equation is true so now for B so
suppose the variation was about an
external node you'd ESSEC then of course
from star we see that the right hand
side just vanishes right
so this is the geodesic equation we see
that delta T and remember this was at
the endpoint is equal to zero so and
then innocuous result but that's
actually Fermat's principle for static
space-time right so it was rather looks
like firmus principle that we've seen
before I've also written down variation
of T which was zero essentially earlier
but now it's different so what exactly
is different does anyone want to comment
so Horace is really differ from firmus
principle in ordinary objects all right
that's true of course so remember what I
said earlier in ordinary optics what is
stationary is the total travel time the
total travel time of the library and of
course the for length of a Nalgene s60
it's not the total travel time the
station in gr it's actually the arrival
time that's - tree that's a local
property so you can see you can see that
it makes sense in general activity we're
not looking at the whole of the null
curve we're just looking at the arrival
time that's station ok so let me make
the statement over there
there's a theorem
so it's essentially firma now of course
Fermat has not used that language but
that's what is what it boils down to in
India and it's actually true for
stationary space-time as well so for
stationary space-time knowledge in Essex
satisfy satisfy that the variation of
the arrival time is equal to zero so the
stationary arrival time and the proof of
this well I mean for stationary
space-time that's actually quite
complicated but for static space times
you've basically seen it we've gone over
the argument right so sweet on this okay
so this is firmus principle
not necessarily so depends on whether
they were emitted at the same time right
I think I can show you an example later
so now let's look at what this means for
our problem of defining spatial light
race in generality all right so let's go
to the problem of optical geometry so my
Fermat's principle
we know that light rays correspond to
curves which satisfy this condition I
mean in the way that I've explained it
now what is actually this T for
stationary spacetimes so earlier in the
lecture you've seen the most general
form for station space-time let's just
solve for DT and well I mean that was
robbed off though due to my huge
handwriting I'm sorry anyway so the term
would have been will have been plus or
minus
it would be something like this right
yes that's the variation that's it sorry
it's the same as fear right but as we've
seen variation of the arrival time but
now of course in order to compute this
we would look at the you know the the
the time interval of our line element so
for station space and this would be the
time interval of the line element to in
order to determine the light race then
we will integrate this and I would keep
the emission time fixed and then very
right
so actually light rays are of course
just the generic procedure light rays
are Jude Essex of of this line element
all right now this looks rather
unfamiliar we have a Romanian here
right but here we have something else
it's a one form really isn't it so DT is
not really given by a Romanian line
element for station space times in
general there's an additional bit so you
can see now that the geometry of spatial
light rays for stationary space times is
actually rather interesting it's not
Romanian geometry at all it's something
more general and actually this is a line
element for something called fin solid
geometry which you may have heard before
but I'm not going to go into details of
this so if you later in the course maybe
do rotating black holes you know cur
blur cause this is what describes the
light rays in curve but now in order to
you know do calculations here for this
lecture we just go back to static space
terms for the first times that we have
proof flow is principal so again we take
Omega H be equal to zero and then of
course the metric you can see becomes
very easy the optical metric is just a
Riemannian metric right Romania metric
of um space yes oh I'm just solving for
logistics of the line element we had
before remember we're stationary
spacetime D s squared is equal to minus
three squared and some table as I've
written down earlier sorry it's been
wrapped off of course we're just looking
for at large in Essex ods zero right now
condition and then rearrange solve for
DT right so the spatial light rays are
actually genetics of this optic you
metric let me just summarize with 90
desks in space-time all right so let's
suppose we have a static space-time this
is where Omega is equal to zero or can
have a stationary space-time this is
where Omega a is nonzero I'd say this
corresponds to an optical geometry so
the geometry of the spatial light rays
my farmers principle and then for static
space-time as you can see this is
romanian optical geometry and for
stationary space-time it's more
complicated I'm not going to go into the
details of this of course this is a
fenceless metric of particular type
called Randers so randa's fins la fin
surrenders we've actually introduced
early on back in the 1940s Randers used
a line element like this to describe
space-time so he wants to introduce a
preferred direction of time in while in
in a spacetime
context of course that's not you know
Lorentz symmetry of course but anyway
here certainly arises in the context of
optics but from now on of course we will
just look at static space times in order
to actually do calculations so the
static space times we can see from what
I've written down over here the line
element will be DT squared is H a B over
V squared DX a DX B right now we have a
line element in three dimensional
Romanian space where this is called the
optical metric let's call it energy
twiddle ad DX a DX P
it's optical metric so it's a Romanian
metric just with a signature plus plus
plus it's in this particular case is
really a property of the space-time and
so the space-time as a whole is a static
spacer there's also the notion of a
let's say a stationary observer so you
can if you look at the at the motion to
say in the space of a black hole you can
define up service that are fixed with
respect to the to the coordinates rather
freely falling there are various ways of
defining statics station observers but
that's the property of the entire
space-time it's a special space-time
only only certain so it's only true for
certain space times which are static or
stationary so I will now move on to the
two Schwarzschild space-time that you've
met before
that's a particular example of a static
space time and there was a stationary
space times for example if you have a
rotating black hole occur because that
would be a station space-time it's a
property of the entire space right so
now to actually do calculations let's
let's look at water
and that's basically because in in the
safe specimen preferred direction
because of the rotation let's say of the
black hole there's particular directions
are actually mesons from the knowledge
in essex where they go one way or the
other way so you get two different
directions and that's encoded by this
Omega a in the case of a stationary
space-time like cur this then would
actually depend on you know the angular
momentum of a black hole but anyway
there's all far too complicated let's
just keep it simple and look at the
Romanian obstacles origin of Schwarz
right right so for small side let me
write down the line element which you've
seen before of course
Isis Warchild in all its glory the line
element in space-time now what's the
corresponding optical metric optical
geometry
what are you the same thing as before
we're looking for knowledge geodesics in
space-time the s square is equal to zero
right we rearranged for T if you like so
excuse me you can immediately see DT
squared sorry is it what is the R
squared over one minus two M over R
squared plus R squared divided by one
minus two M over R into what around
metric on s to write into water are
coordinates and well as you know by
symmetry every plane through through the
centre of a coordinate system is a
totally genetic SAP manifold so the
light rays will actually stay in a plane
in a plane through the origin so without
loss of generality we can we can exploit
the symmetry we can set theta to be
equal to PI by two in other words where
you know on the on the equatorial plane
if you like but really any plane through
the origin will do and then the problem
becomes even simpler right we're just
left with DT squared is equal to the R
squared over 1 minus 2 m over are all
squared plus asked when T Phi squared
divided by 1 minus 2 M of R and again
from what we've seen before by Fermat's
principle we know that special light
rays will be geodesics of this optical
metric G twiddle a B
written in a simple diagram form so
that's good done right it's really just
this diagonal metric so it's the metric
of a surface right very simple problem
but how can we understand Jude Essex of
the surface so of course one way of
thinking about the surface when you're
given a line inment is to try and embed
it isometrically in high dimensional
space right that's the surface
two-dimensional let's try and see what
it looks like by embedding it
isometrically in r3 or III right so in
three dimensional Euclidean space what
does that mean well probably know this
anyway so here's again our line element
so what we want this to be is it's an
isometric debating we want this to be
the Euclidean metric in three
dimensional space let's say I mean by by
exploiting this symmetry that we have
that same we look at cylindrical
coordinates all right so we want
something like DZ squared plus the R
squared plus R square T Phi squared
and well it's probably make sense to
identify the polar coordinates we use
the same polar coordinates in the
optical metric as well as in our
embedding geometry so we identify the
Phi's so that of course tells us that
the function big R which will be a
function of our little earth will be
given by when I say R over square root
of 1 minus 2 M over R right and of
course what we like to determine is a
function of Z as I said as a function of
big R right then we have a cylindrical
polar equation III and then we see what
the surface actually looks like so now
by by rearranging then you see that we
have to determine 1 over 1 minus 2 M
over R or squared is equal to those
terms go we divide is equal to DZ r by
dr squared plus the R big R of little R
by the little are all squared okay so in
press we can see how to do this we have
big R of little R we can work this out
so we can determine D Z by D little R I
mean it's just algebra you can rearrange
it I'm looking too good no but of course
what we like to do is we like to express
this as DZ by D big R and what you will
find is the following it's for M R
little R minus 9 mm squared divided by
little R minus 3 M will squared right
and all of this this is in terms of
little R you should actually also
express in terms of big R but you can
see this that's not easy at all right
you really have to integrate invert and
so on but we don't actually need to do
this we can we can look at this
expression and find out about of this
embedded surface actually looks like
so let's note few things well first of
all this embedding will only work if the
numerator is is non-negative rights of
the embedding words if little are you
know original optical coordinates is
greater than nine closest of em and as
you will observe of course this is
actually bigger than 2m 2 and a quarter
right so even though the optical
geometry is defined all the way to the
horizon to the event horizon the
embedding at least in these coordinates
only works up to two and a quarter of M
so it's absolutely before the horizon
but I mean physically that is not
actually important what else can we see
what about the asymptotics so let's
suppose we go to great distance a long
way away from for a black hole you see
from this equation immediately that big
R is essentially little are they
approach each other and and then we also
see that is it by the little R will go
to where go to what will go through 4 m
/ R so then in the limit we can also
write it as 4 m / big R that's of course
square right so you can you can see what
said of R will look like in the limit we
take the square root so this looks like
for spirit of M oh that's right no no
yeah okay yeah it comes in so anyway
last distance you see the surface will
actually look like well you like the
square root of far yes what about
this point we see desert by the our
diverges at little R is equal to 3m now
actually this is not a problem if you
write in terms of big R you just have to
believe me you can do it if you change
the coordinates what this means however
is that there's a photon orbit you might
have seen this in your in your tutorials
in Schwarzschild so it's the radius of
of a circular photo an orbit in in
smartphone so we've now got enough
information to sort of draw it at large
distance it looks like you know like a
like a square root function so this is
no Z right as a function it's in the
plane of big R and Phi then there's this
throat alright this is at little R equal
to 3 M and the embedding breaks down a
little bit further in let's say here
this is little R equal to nine quarters
of M and that's what it looks like
okay so this interesting shape with a
throw to waste here now the statement
again from firmus principle is that
spatial light rays will correspond to
Jude Essex of the surface all right so
it's really what it says let's suppose
we have a light source which will be
sitting somewhere here we have an
observer sitting somewhere else we work
out the geodesic on the surface where
that's going to be a light ray okay so
we wants to once you see what this looks
like get some intuition it's an
isometric embedding all right so
therefore we can talk about your desks
of this particular embedded surface okay
yeah it's quite optical distance and of
course a large distance it really just
becomes spatial distance because
obviously in Schwarzschild as you move
far away you're basically in flat space
right so really the optical it is any
vacuum the optical distance is really
just the Euclidean distance in this
picture but as you move closer to the
horizon this is what it looks like and
what once you determine yes well no so
the the space-time as so the space where
is static we're all sort of theorizing
right this is what you mean - listen
there's a limit of statistic but all
what we do is certainly outside of 2m
and the state especially was perfectly
static in this much higher case it will
be stationary in the case of Kerr right
also I think what other region okay yes
well it's a bit tedious I'm not going to
go over it but in principle you can see
I'll do it how far we have read off from
this identification or as you can
differentiate you get one complicated
expression terms of little R then you
can solve for DZ by D or in terms of
liquor right there's something can write
down but then you can use the chain rule
by shaking right down over here at this
right and we can just write down DZ by
the bigger in terms of DZ by D little R
with this factor but of course we can
simply get it from here right third
problem the problem is actually to write
this expression on the right hand side
in terms of big R that's even more
tedious but there's no problem in
getting getting to this okay so now we
want to discuss you know lensing in some
sense the reflection of light rays now
in order to to do this we have to
understand how the curvature of this
surface impinges on the propagation of
light rays right so let's think about
that
covington like this and um the quantity
that is actually interesting for us is
the Gaussian curvature of the surface so
you may or may not have seen the concept
of Gaussian curvature before
geometrically it's the product of the
two principal curvatures now if you look
at the surface and you know the
background it's immediately obvious that
the Gaussian curvature of the surface is
everywhere does any one spot it thank
you
so we have two principal curvatures
wherever if you like we have a curvature
in in there goes the curvature in this
direction so curving in and we have a
curvature in that direction going out
that tells you the two principal
curvatures have opposite sign the
Gaussian curvature is the product so the
Gaussian curvature is actually negative
everywhere and this is very surprising
if you think about this well I'll come
back to this later anyway let's look at
what Gaussian curvature actually is and
why it's negative on the surface
everywhere
so you've seen curvature of course in
terms of the Riemann tensor the notation
might be slightly different I'm used to
that but you'll see that everybody does
it differently in books so you just have
to get used to it that's what are you
and this is for vector fields that
commute and writing it in terms of
recorded in do spaces this is how I read
off the components so it's a b c d
there's a face right forward
and now what Scouts in curvature now
because this is a property of a surface
of a two dimensional manifold right now
in terms of a surface now you're
familiar with the symmetries of the
Riemann tensor how many independent
components is the Riemann tensor have in
two dimensions one right so if you write
on our ABCD you know you have anti
symmetry in the past and symmetry off
the pairs of course if you only have two
coordinates there's this one one
combination that's going to be non
vanishing right and this number we call
the Gaussian curvature it was you two
defined up to a sign so I defined like
this it's K Gaussian curvature K into
now we have to respect the symmetries of
course that's G a I think is 80 gb c - g
AC g BD like this that's the gaussian
curvature so let's suppose to be a bit
more general let's suppose our surface
is traumatized by u and v coordinates U
and V and we have a line element on the
surface that's given by G u squared plus
f of U squared D V squared right so it's
a symmetric surface so it's used for
formula that you can use in more general
context of course we want to apply to
that particular optical problem but
let's say we have a surface given by
this line element
I'm just looking at commuting vector
fields so I think you use all these
factories from so you know if you have a
coordinate induced vector field of
course that manages so then if you like
it's a lemma so the Gaussian curvature
of the surface has a very simple form
it's simply given by - the second
derivative of F divided by F so it's
nice little formula so let's try and
prove this in general
okay proof so we have to work out this
Riemann curvature tensor for this very
simple metrics like an exercise right
well first of all what are the
non-vanishing connection components the
lady treats our connection components
for this metric
what's the metric so this is G twiddle
well it's simply one F squared of U 0 0
nice a diagonal metric very simple and
you can convince yourselves that there's
only two non-vanishing connection
components it's V u U and V u v and
everything else zero so what are they
well this will be 1/2 g v wants the
diagonal metrics so we only left with G
V V upstairs and then you know G V u
comma u two of them minus G u u comma V
1 of course they're no off diagonal
terms that goes so we're left with 1/2
times 1 right what's the inverse metric
it's just the the in the inverse of a
diagonal metric is just the metric of
the diagonal components all over the
diagonal components so it's 1/2 times 1
times minus the derivative of this with
respect to other celery round actually
that's right
sorry yeah so it's u VV
that makes more sense
levy car you ah right so 1/2 times
Guu that's one right times minus g VV /
differentiate respect to you so this is
minus 2 FF primed so this is yes at once
- F F Prime this is right everybody
agrees sorry why because it's it's an
often it's an off time the term medina
metric and the other non vanishing
connection component is actually this so
it's 1/2 g VV upstairs now into what g v
u comma V + G V V comma u - g u v comma
v these are the angle terms they're 0
now we're left with 1/2 times where g VV
upstairs is 1 over f squared and this is
g VV comma u so this is now again FF
primed so now we get plus F prime over F
ok yes right no no yeah yeah that's just
notational I mean I guess you've seen
you know rotations like this in terms of
the coordinates we here we just have two
coordinates for the surface yes of
course there's no information like I
said these are the truth the only two
non vanishing connection ones so now we
can work out the Riemann tensor well
what about our UV UV well this will be K
into g UV
g b u- g uu g VV right what is that well
that's actually K times minus the
determinant of the metric G twiddle so
we see now that the Gaussian curvature K
is actually minus the component R UV UV
/ that's G what I'm afraid we have to
work it out what is that
G it's just F squared right so it's
month it's minus 1 over F squared into
by this component of 3 month n so now we
have to write it out now again that
depends on the conventions you choose
I've chosen this convention if you do
this you get gamma okay actually I have
given you this component I have to pull
down one of the indices easily done it's
a diagonal metric guu is 1 anyway right
so this is U V u comma V minus gamma u V
V comma u plus gamma gamma u v u a Z
minus gamma gamma V V you a you write in
all its glory there are no connection
components that have you upstairs and
you downstairs we think we know
immediately this is 0 this will be 0 2
so we're left with minus 1 over F
squared into well gamma u UV is F prime
over F so that's minus F prime over F
primed plus
okay what about this we have a you
upstairs we downstairs the only
connection component that survives will
be the V V component right so out of
this is no electrical some right over a
but the only component that survives
from the summation will be that and this
is equal to well minus FF primed into F
prime over F so let's see what is this
strange uvv oh yeah sorry this is
actually this was minus FF primed yes
that makes more sense so we get from
this we get a plus F F double prime plus
F prime squared minus F prime square
there cancer all right and we just get
plus F F double Prime so indeed we do
get minus F double prime divided by F
that's required all right so that's the
proof
nice little em'ly yes see let's see that
it actually makes sense so example let's
look at the atmosphere the round sphere
well spheres are always wrong right I
mean the sphere with the round metric so
let's say our surface it's just given by
that all right you know this what's the
Gaussian curvature of the sphere well
actually you can think of the Gaussian
curvature as 1 over the radius of
curvature squared of a sphere that's
oscillating your surface of oscillating
sphere and of course if you have a
sphere in the first place the osculating
is for instance fear itself if it's unit
sphere like s2 of course the radius of
coating would be 1 right so we expect K
to be equal to 1 and one of these is so
yes but if you know Latin of course
osteo means the kiss right actually
buckram was and so it's the kissing
circle because it touches the surface
not just in the first derivative but
actually in the second derivative as
well which is all-important as you know
do these things okay sorry
so U is theta V is Phi F of you are
function f is just sine sine theta right
so the Gaussian curvature
according to lemma is minus f double
prime divided by F so it's minus sine
cos cos t minus sine right
so it's minus sine theta divided by sine
theta so indeed it is plus 1 as expected
okay so it makes sense right so now this
is the Gaussian curvature and I mean I
come to lensing after the after the
break let's just before the break
applies to to the optical geometry of
Schwarzschild and see what we get all
right so now apply the for child to the
Schwarzschild optical geometry well
again DT squared was what was it was d R
squared over 1 minus 2 M over R squared
plus R squared D Phi squared over 1
minus 2 M over R right so now to apply
this we make another identification we
say okay let well I certainly let V be
equal to Phi and we identify the the
polar coordinate again excuse me what
about you well we can certainly say that
GU right by comparing the first
respective first terms D you will be er
divided by 1 minus 2 M over R so we
really have to express licky you in
terms of little R in order to to work
out the Gaussian curvature and you can
see that that's rather tedious you have
to integrate up change coordinates
differentiate and so on let's try and be
a bit more clever than this so we know
that K is minus 1 over f d squared f of
u by u square right
now of course this is that's the same as
1 over F into D by D you actually it's
right in terms of of our so I want to
write as d by dr dr by d you into the R
by D you the F of R by D are mass of
changing coordinates we can do it in the
differentiation also and you can see
there's actually helpful because if you
work this out what is it it's 1 over f
into dr by d you d by dr of PR by d you
d f of r phi dr right plus the other
term which will be this derivative
acting on that so it will be dr by d u
squared times d squared f of r by dr
squared and of course f of r we can
actually read off from the line element
right the way this I named it was set up
this fourth factor here is f squared of
our right where F of R is really is
really what is R divided by square root
of 1 minus 2 M over R and everything is
given now you can just plug it in right
differentiate it's always easier than
integrating we can certainly work on the
second derivative of this dr by d you
will also know from our identification
what what we mean by u dr by do is what
is just 1 minus 2 M over R and this
again you can differentiate respect to R
no problem there right differentially
inspector you would be more difficult
anyway you can plug this in immediately
just work it out
and get the answer and the answer is
after some work K is equal to minus two
M over R cubed into 1 minus 3 M over 2 R
and that's it so the term script curl
collect nicely and remember we're in the
static part of the space-time of course
are I mean I also have the horizon
anyway we were outside of 2 m this is
three-halves m so you see the bracket is
actually always positive right so we see
the Gaussian curvature of the
Schwarzschild optical geometry is indeed
negative everywhere so like I said
before if you know about principal
curvatures the surfaces
it would have been immediately obvious
anyway from from the picture that I that
I drew earlier but now going through all
these shenanigans we can also see
analytically that the Gaussian curvature
is always negative
so before we stop for the break let me
just make one observation
so we know that the Gaussian curvature
is negative what does that tell us for
the Jude Essex so if you have a surface
with a negative Gaussian curvature
remember the geodesics on the surface
are our light rays right so if the
gaussian curvature is negative this
actually means that the geodesics have
to diverge and they diverge everywhere
so how is it possible for the light rays
to reconvert somewhere else that you
have multiple images as you see in
pictures yesterday and the answer is
that's a global effect so we have now
got to connect the local properties of
the surface the curvature to the global
property of the surface the topology and
we do this by Gauss Bernay so I think
I'll use after the break